that's the news this morning let's start
with this a key Republican senator says
the Trump administration needs to
explain how for US Army sergeants were
killed in the air
Bryan black Jeremiah Johnson Dustin
right and Ladera Johnson were told not
to expect enemy contact on their mission
to meet with community leaders just over
two weeks ago they were stationed in de
share with hundreds of other US troops
working with local forces to fight
terrorism President Trump did not
mention the lost soldiers until Monday
then he was criticized for how he spoke
to the widow of one of the men who was
killed the president says he said
nothing inappropriate Margaret Brennan
is at the White House Margaret good
morning good morning
well us Africa Command is investigating
the ambush to see if any warning signs
were missed Senate Armed Services
Committee chairman John McCain says the
administration is not being upfront and
he's demanding more information about
this attack sergeant Lee David Johnson
was one of four soldiers killed on
patrol in a chair more than two weeks
ago in a pre mission debriefing they
were told no enemy contact expected but
the group about 40 and all were attacked
by militants who the Pentagon now
believes are part of an offshoot of Isis
the patrol that was attacked last week
had actually done 29 patrols without
contact over the previous six months or
so no indication that this was going to
occur their attackers were described as
well-trained well-equipped and well
organized and with no armed aircraft
overhead to call on for airstrikes
against their attackers the Green Berets
were trapped the first aircraft to
arrive were French Mirage jets they were
able to have close air support overhead
about 30 minutes after first contact but
it was too late for sergeants Bryan
black Dustin Wright and Jeremiah Johnson
who were mortally wounded sergeant Lee
David Johnson was also killed his body
not recovered until two days later his
wife is expecting their third child
President Trump called his widow Myesha
Johnson as she was on her way to receive
his body Florida Democrat Frederica
Wilson was with Johnson I heard him say
well he knew what he was signing up for
sergeant Johnson's mother confirmed
Wilson's version of events to the
Washington Post saying the president
disrespected her son but president Trump
claimed it was fabricated I did not say
what she said had a very nice
conversation with the woman with the
wife who has sounded like a lovely woman
did not say what the congresswoman said
now the issue of how these gold star
families are treated has now become a
political football yesterday the White
House said that President Trump wrote a
personal $25,000 check to the family of
an army corporal who had been killed in
Afghanistan now his family says they
haven't received it Gail a similar
controversy happened after President
Obama was delayed in writing a check to
memorialize Isis hostage Kayla Mueller
all right Margaret Brennan thank you
very much